I often get asked if I think I'm ever
going to build something useful and
maybe someday I will but the way I see
it I already have because I've built
myself this job it's something that I
can never have planned for instead it
happened just because I was enthusiastic
about what I was doing and I was sharing
that enthusiasm with other people to me
there's the true beauty of making
useless things because it's this
acknowledgment that you don't always
know what the best answer is and it
turns off that voice in your head that
tells you that you know exactly how the
world works and maybe a toothbrush
helmet isn't the answer but at least
you're asking the question